si monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur luc chatel merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
depuis cinq ans les gouvernements
successifs auxquels vous avez appartenu
se sont efforcés de délaisser la
ruralité et je voudrais vous en donner
quelques exemples précis nous installons
actuellement le bureau des
intercommunalités des nouvelles
intercommunalités
je veux dénoncer ici la méthode qui a
prévalu qui a consisté à imposer des
périmètres intercommunaux au forceps
sans parfois l'aval des élus eux mêmes
en instaurant des assemblées de plus de
100 élus en milieu rural quasiment
ingouvernable il y a pire monsieur le
premier ministre
avec des intercommunalités ou des élus
qui avaient été choisies au moment des
élections municipales fléchés pour
sécher siéger à l'intercommunalité qui
ont été démis de leurs fonctions
c'est clairement un déni de démocratie
monsieur communisme je pense à l'abandon
de la ruralité
quand je vois que la baisse des
dotations s'effectue invariablement face
aux collectivités qui gèrent avec
minutie et qui gère sérieusement leurs
finances et celles qui sont toujours
dans la fuite en avant
je pense à l'abandon de la ruralité
quand les trains d'équilibré du
territoire pour ceux qui n'avaient pas
disparus sont aujourd'hui transféré aux
régions
sans aucune garantie de financement et
c'est dans ce contexte monsieur le
premier ministre que vous annoncez une
réforme des préfectures les préfectures
dit nouvelle génération qui va à nouveau
éloigné les centres de décision et les
services au public quand il faudra faire
100 ou 200 km pour une carte grise a
permis de conduire ou un passeport
oui ça éloigne le service public donc
oui aux réductions de la dépense
publique monsieur premier ministre oui à
une meilleure organisation de l'état
mais pas contre les élus pas contre le
service au public
ma question est donc simple quand c'est
serez vous de vous en prendre à la
ruralité
la parole est à monsieur jean michel
baylet me
l'aménagement du territoire de la
ruralité et des collectivités
territoriales merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député luc chatel
ou ne l'occasion de dire que jamais
depuis bien longtemps
un gouvernement ait fait autant en
direction de la ruralité
vous aviez à 5 ans réunit deux comités
ministériels ou de lancer trois en 14
mois et 104 mesures dont les contrats de
ruralité qui remporte un succès
considérable sans déjà signé trois cents
à la fin du premier trimestre et la
différence est que l'action que vous
veniez c'est qu'ils sont financés car
s'il est vrai que nous avons demandé aux
collectivités de participer à l'effort
de redressement des comptes publics
mon collègue christian acadien de vous
rappeler dans quel état était la phrase
lorsque vous gouverner nous avons pu
grâce aux efforts de l'état les
collectivités redresser les comptes
publics
ce qui a permis aux preneurs et puis
lors du congrès des maires de diminuer
par deux l'effort demandé pour 2017
c'est donc un milliard supplémentaire
dans la quête des collectivités qui
c'est vrai sont l'objet d'une ambitieux
de réformes en particulier
l'intercommunalité réforme qui se
déroule dans les meilleures conditions à
quelques excès à quelques exceptions
près je vous la corde puisque 85%
m'entendais bien justement écouté mon
bien 85% des schémas départementaux ont
été votés par les élus et les passer
outre des préfets ont été très rares et
nous ancrer des intercommunalités qui
ont désormais les moyens de bien
fonctionner donc oui la ruralité est
notre priorité
avec l'augmentation de 62 % de la
dotation des qui dit qu d'équipement des
territoires ruraux
là deux terres en 3 ha oui la réalité
notre priorité à mes la création d'une
usine 1 milliard d'euros en 2007
un milliard deux en 2017 dont 600
millions d'euros
fait chier pour la rivalité oui monsieur
le député la rue
lité mais la mairie ne tienne